[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر البركه
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زوايا ومن جميع جواب
المسيحيين الشرقيين واوكرانيا ترفض وتصفها
بالنفاق
دين الانتخابات
[تصفيق]
يوم ثالث في الكونجرس لانتخاب رئيس مجلس
النواب وخلافات الجمهوريين على حالها
وسيكون لدينا ايضا
في كتاب جديد الامير هاري يتهموا شقيقه
ويليام بضربه ويقول انه عملت قطعه غيار
احتياطيه
لم يمر الكثير من الوقت على اعلان
لمناسبه اعياد المسيحيين الشرق
رئاسه الاوكرانيه قال ان اعلان وقف اطلاق
النار الروسيه
من خلاله لكسب الوقت ويضيفه ان هذا
الاعلان محظو دعايه تريد من خلاله روسيا
التقليل من حده المعارك التي تتعرض لها
مشيرا ايضا الى ان بوتن لا يرغب في انهاء
الحرب
36 ساعه على طول خط الجبهه مع اوكرانيا
حتى منتصف الليل اليوم التالي وطلب الكامل
الاوكرانيا بمنح الفرصه للمواطنين لاداء
طقوس الاحتفال باعياد المسيحيين الشرقيين
لكنه اوكرانيا كما ذكرنا رمضان وطلب روسيا
من سحاب من كل الاراضي التي سيطرت عليها
قبل الحديث عنه وهو طبعا امر مستعد لانه
قال قبل ساعات انه مستعد لمحاد السلام مع
اوكرانيا اذا اعترفت بالواقع الجديد
الموجود على ارض المعارك لترد اوكرانيا
ايضا بان امرا كهذا مستحيل الحدوث وبينما
يزداد الحديث عن السلام تقول المعارك
العكس تماما فهناك معارك محتدمه في مخموت
في الشرق تريد روسيا سيطر عليها ثم تدخل
بلا روسيا ورئيسها اليكساندر لوكاتشينكو
حديث بوتن الاقرب يدخل على خط تضييق
الخناق على اوكرانيا فقد طالبت بلا روسيا
كل الذكور في الدوله من منهم في سن الخدمه
العسكريه بالذهاب الى مراكز التجنيد الامر
الذي يثير تكهنات حول تعبئه جديده محتمله
ثم تعلن وزاره الدفاع البلاء روسيه عن
تعزيز التدريبات المشتركه مع روسيا كما
تعلن عن اجراء تدريبات جويه مشتركه فيما
تحذر اوكرانيا من تعرضها الاشتياح من
الشمال
من مدينه شيرني جوف على الحدود الاوكرانيه
البيلاروسيه حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه
اهلا بك معنا حذيفه الى ما تشير كل
المعطيات على الارض على الحدود الاوكرانيه
البيلاروسيه لجهه امكانيه حدوث اجتياح
محتمل او تطوير على الاقل المشاركه
البلاروسيه في هذه الحرب على اوكرانيا
نعم تحياتي طاهر يعني على الرغم من
الاستفزازات وعلى الرغم من حدوث المناوشات
هنا وهناك بين الجانب الروسي والجانب
الاوكراني الا ان الجنود الاوكرانيين
والضباط هنا في الحدود الاوكرانيه البلا
الروسيه وكنت وقد زرت اليوم الحدود وتجول
في عده مناطق فيها وتحدثت اليهم قالوا
انهم مطمئنين تماما لخطوط الدفاعات التي
قاموا بانشائها وكان الجدار او عمليه زرع
الالغام الواسعه او همم الخنادق وخطوط
الدفاع من من الحدود نفسها وحتى العاصمه
كيف هم متوانين لعدم قدره القوات الروسيه
على الزحف مره اخرى نحو العاصمه كيف هنالك
انتشار كبير جدا هنالك عمليه زرع الغرام
واسعه جدا في الحدود وحتى على مستويات عده
الى الداخل او الى العمق الاوكراني لذلك
هم مستعدين كذلك الكسندر بلوك وهو قائد
همم القوات الدفاع عن الاكيف ايضا قال ان
خطوط الدفاع عن كيف تبدا من الحدود حتى
العاصمه اكيد وقال ان لن يتكرر ذات
السيناري الذي حدث في الرابع والعشرين من
فبراير هو الاتجاه عن طريق الاراضي
الشماليه والوصول بهذه السرعه نحو العاصمه
طيب همم ماذا همم تقول المعطيات بخصوص
امكانيه ان يعني يتمدد الصراع اكثر من
الجانب الاوكراني السياسي الرسمي اتحدث هل
هناك ايه توعدات بامكانيه ان تتوسع الحرب
من جانب النت وايضا اذا ما اشمل التروسيا
بيلاروسيا اكثر في هذه الحرب وحصل فعلا
اجتياح او تطور اكبر على الحدود البلار
روسيه الاوكرانيه
نعم تحديدا حول ذلك طبعا لم تتحدث السلطات
الاوكرانيه والجانب الاوكراني وحتى دول
حلف الناتو لم تصرح حول ذلك ولكن هنالك
طبعا تكهلات من قبل بعض المحللين سواء كان
السياسيين او العسكريين حول امكانيه حول
عمليه دخول النت في هذه الحرب اذا ما حدثت
خروقات من بيلاروسيا في اتجاه
الدول وخاصه ان كان هنالك بعض التهديدات
التي همم طالت الدول القريبه من بلا روسيا
همم من قبل الرئيس همم اللوكيشن من مدينه
الشرق على الحدود الاوكرانيه البلا روسيه
حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك
كان هدف الشمال لكن في الشرق تعد بخموط
احد اكثر ساحات المعارك دراوطا وسخونه
تدافع عنها القوات الاوكرانيه بقوه وتمثل
تحديا كبيرا للقوات الروسيه فل نتعرف اذا
على اهميتها تقع محمود على ضفتين نهر
العام
2571 وهي اقدم مركز تاريخي وثقافي في
المقاطعه اهميه المدينه الجغرافيه في انها
تقع على طريق رئيسه تؤدي الى مدينتي
كرامات
وهما من اكبر مدن اقليم دون بس القلب
الصناعي للبلاد تكتمل اهميه
بالقرب من الطريق الدولي امس 03 الذي
يصلها مباشره بمدينه اسلام
اكبر المدن الاوكرانيه تبلغ مساحه 41
كلم مربعا ويبلغ عدد سكانها
71,000ا بحسب احصاء 20 21
وبسبب الحرب فر 90% من السكان وفقا
مسؤولين اوكرانيين اليوم تحدث مسؤول
امريكي عن ان الوضع في مخموت غير واضح
تماما واشار الى احراز القوات الروسيه
تقدما تدريجيا في الايام القليله الماضيه
الاهميه الاستراتيجيه للمدينه قد تراها
مسك هديه ثمينه تسوقها داخل المجتمع على
انها انتصار معنوي كبير في حال سقطت بايدي
قوتها خصوصا انها في امس الحاجه لذلك عقب
ضربه مافيا الموجعه
الحرب في محمود تمثل جزء من معركه اوسع
يتسع نطاقها يوما بعد يوم باستخدام اسلحه
غير تقليديه الطائرات المسيره لجات اليها
موسكو بالمساعده وامداد من حليفتها
المعاقبه طهران المسيارات الايرانيه يبدو
انها تحتل الاولويه
136 التي اسقطت احداها من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه وبقيت سليمه لتعينها
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه
تمثلت بان اجزاء من شاهد 136 مصنعه من قبل
اثنتي عشره شركه امريكيه وغربيه وفقا
لتقييم الاستخباراتيا اوكراني حصلت شبكه
سي ان ان الامريكيه عليها التقييم
والاستخباراتيه الاوكراني يوضح انه من بين
52 مكونه تمت ازالتها من الطائره
الايرانيه شاهد 136 يبدو ان 40 مكونا تم
تصنيعها بواسطه اثنتي عشره شركه امريكيه
مختلفه والاجزاء المتبقيه صنعت بواسطه
شركات من كندا سويسرا اليابان تايوان
والصين امر يمثل تحديا لاداره الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن اليس كذلك وهي التي
تعاهدت بالحد من برنامج ايران للطائرات
المسيره لكن ورغم القيود الصارمه استطاع
الطهران توصل الى التكنولوجيا الامريكيه
الحساسه واستطعت استخدامها الغريب انه لا
يوجد دليل يشير الى ان اي من هذه الشركات
تتعارض مع قوانين العقوبات الامريكيه
وتقوم بتصدير تقنيتها عن قصد الاستخدامها
في الطائره بدون طيار لا دليل على ذلك الا
ان مراقبه وتتبع المنتجات يمثل صعوبه
كبيره امام شركه
[موسيقى]
من هنا اصبح الاتجاه لمنع ايران من تصنيع
المسيرات اكثر الحاحا مع استمرار روسيا في
نشرها في جميع انحاء اوكرانيا بدراوه لا
هواده فيها اضافه الى استعداد موسكو
لانشاء مصنعها الخاص لانتاجها بمساعده
طهران وفقا لمسؤولينا امريكيين تحقيق
منفصل للطائرات الايرانيه بشان المسيارات
الايرانيه التي تم اسقاطها في اوكرانيا
اجرته شركه
كونفلكتارتش ومقرها المملكه المتحده توصل
الى ان 82% من المكونات تم تصنيعها من قبل
شركه مقرها امريكا ونقلت سي ان عن نائب
مدير العمليات في كونفلكت ارمانتريس قوله
ان العقوبات لن تكون فعاله الا اذا استمرت
الحكومات في مراقبه الاجزاء التي يتم
استخدامها وكيف وصلت الى هناك اضاف ان
ايران وروسيا تحاولان الالتفاف على تلك
العقوبات وتغيير قنوات الاستحوا خاصه بهما
وهذا بالضبط ما يجب التركيز عليه تتبع
المكونات ومراقبه التغييرات هناك تحدي اخر
على اوكرانيا وامريكا خوضه او ايجاد حله
على الاقل فالطائرات المسيره الايرانيه
تكلفتها الزاهيده تتراوح بين 20 و 50,000
دولار بينما السلاح الذي يسقطها يكلف كيف
ما بين 120 و500,000 دولار تخيلوا الفرق
هذا مشكله متناهيه لاوكرانيا ولحلفائها
فنظامنا الشمس على سبيل المثال الذي
تحدثنا عنه كثيرا هنا هو نظام دفاع جوي
قصير الى متوسط المدى ارسلته واشنطن الى
كياف في نوفمبر اطلاقه بحسب ما ذكرت صحيفه
تايمز يكلف 500 الف دولار تنقل الصحيفه عن
خبرين عسكريين قولهما ان اطلاق صواريخ
بقيمه اربعه ملايين دولار والقصد هنا
الباتريوت على 250 الف دولار من صواريخ
روز روسيه قد يكون مبررا اذا اصابت تلك
الصواريخ اهداف حساسه بينما اطلاق صواريخ
بقيمه 4 ملايين دولار على طائره ايرانيه
بدون طيار من طراز شاهد 136 بقيمه 50,000
دولار ان يستحق الامر ذلك لن يستحق
وبالتالي المعضله تستمر حتى تجد واشنطن
حلا وهو ما تعمل عليه الان
[موسيقى]
البيت الابيض يقول الان انه قرر وبرلين
ارسال مدرعات الى اوكرانيا
وهناك توافق مع المانيا على دعم اوكرانيا
بالدفاعات الجويه اخر ما يرد عن البيت
الابيض فيما يخص الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
وكذلك هناك اخبار عاجله عن قاض ايراني
يطلب من المدعي العام فتح تحقيق بيتها
اغتصاب واعتداءات جنسيه بحق سجينات متابعه
ايضا كل الاخبار
التظاهرات الايرانيه المستمره في سياق
نشاطنا تجري تركيا انتخابات قد تحدد مصيره
حزب العداله والتنميه الحاكم منذ العام
2003 وبالتالي مصير الرئيس نفسه
الانتخابات ست تشمل الرئاسه والبرلمان
وحددت في الثامن عشر من يونيو 20 23 لكن
الرئيس التركي لما حائل انها قد تزرع بوقت
ابكر قليلا مراعاه للظروف للم بحسب ما
قاله اردوغان اليوم التحدي الاكبر الذي
تواجهه البلاد يتمثل بالاقتصاد انهارت
قيمه الليره بشكل متكرر امام الدولار
لتستقر حاليا عند 18 او عند 18 ليره فاصل
74 مقابل الدولار الواحد وسباقا
للانتخابات المهمه اعلن الرئيس التركي
اجراء تعديل على زياده رواتب الموظفين
الحكوميين والمتقاعدين لتصبح 30 بالمئه
بدلا من 25 بحسب ما اوردته وكاله انباء
الاناضول الرسميه لترتفع اجور المتقاعدين
مثلا من ثلاثه الاف 1500 ليره الى خمسه
الاف 1500 ليره اعتبارا من الشهر الجاري
تعلمون جميعا اهميه الانتخابات قاد يتم
تحديث موعدها ليكون ابكر قليلا في هذا
العام لمراعاه بعض الظروف الموسميه
المتعلقه بالمناخ والاجواء
ومع اقتراب التصويت المصيريه نجد خمس
قضايا تنتظر الحسن في تركيا
وتوصف ضمن مده زمنيه قصيره لا تتعدى
الاربعه اشهر اولها والاكبر هي من ينافس
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان لم تتمكن احزاب
المعارضه من الاتفاق على اسم معين حتى
الان امر يصب بمصلحه الرئيس القضيه
الساخنه الثانيه هي القضايا المرفوعه ضد
المنافس المحتمل رئيس بلديه اسطنبول
الاكرم امام اوغلو الذي حكم بالسجن اكثر
من عامين في قضيه تعود جذورها لتاريخ
تسلمه كرسي البلديه كما يواجه امام اوغلو
قضيه اخرى وهي ادعاء من مفتش وزاره
الداخليه رفعوه للنيابه بشان الادعاء بان
الرجل وظف اشخاصا مرتبطين بالارهاب في
البلديه
القضيه او المعضله الثالثه الخطيره انجاز
التعبير تتمثل بترقب الاوساط التركيه قضيه
تتعلق بحل حزب الشعوب الديمقراطيه المتهم
بوجود صلات له مع حزب العمال الكردستاني
المصنف ارهابيا في تركيا والاتحاد
الاوروبي والولايات المتحده تمهيدا لقرار
الحل ربما قررت المحكمه الدستوريه العليا
اليوم حرمان الحزب مؤقتا من المخصصات
الماليه البالغه
500.39 مليون ليره تركيه اي ما يقارب 29
مليون دولار وذكرت محطه ام تي في في
الخاصه التركيه ان قرار حرمان حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي من المخصصات الماليه اعتمد
بغالبيه ثمانيه اصوات مؤيده ومعارضه سبعه
ونتابع اذا ذكرت ذلك محطه ان تي في الخاصه
القضيه الرابعه المهمه هي قضيه التعديلات
الدستوريه التي طرح رئيس حزب الشعب
الجمهوريه كمال كليتش دار اوغلو ومنها
العوده للنظام البرلماني لكنه اقتراح لم
يمرر طالما بقيا حزب العداله والتنميه
صاحب الاغلبيه في البرلمان اضافه الى
تعديلات اخرى
وتتطلب الموافقه على اجراء تعديل في
الدستور في البرلمان التركي الحصول على
400 صوت واذا ترووحت الاصوات ما بين 360
و400 صوت فانه يمكن نقل او يمكن له ان
يطرح على الاستفتاء الشعبي
[موسيقى]
سياسي
وخارجي على اعتبار ان القضيه الخامسه
ترتبط بجزء اكبر بالسياسه الخارجيه لتركيا
التي شهدت تحولا كبيرا خلال العام الماضي
الا انها تتعلق ايضا بمحددات داخليه من
جهه اخرى كالتطبيعه مع النظام السوري الذي
تحدث اردوغان بخصوصه عن امكانيه اللقاء
بالاسد قريبا بواسطه الروسيه وبعدما تقدم
لا يعرف حتى الان من سيكون له الحظ الاكبر
للفوز في انتخابات الرئاسه في البلاد
خصوصا مع التضارب نتائج استطلاعات الراي
التي يرى مراقبون انها لا تعبر عن نتائج
حاسمه فيما يتوقع البعض ان تحسم
الانتخابات من الجوله الاولى بينما يرى
اخرون ان هذا الامر مستعد وانها ستشهد
جولتين يجب ان يحصل المرشحون على نسبه 50
زائد واحد من الاصوات على الاقل بالمئه
طبعا ليتم انتخابهم لكن وفي حال لم يحصل
اي مرشح على الاغلبيه المطلقه في الجوله
الاولى ستجرى جوله ثانيه بعد 15 يوما بين
المرشحين الذين حصل على اكبر عدد من
الاصوات اولا وبعد ذلك سينتخب المرشح الذي
يحصل على اغلبيه الاصوات الصحيحه رئيسا
لتركيا
اذا وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يقول ان
تهديده الايرانيه على راس اولوياتنا
الدفاعيه معنا من اسطنبول متابعه لشان
التركيه دكتور سمير صالح الاستاذ في
العلاقات الدوليه اهلا بك معنا دكتور كنا
نقول انه تبقى النتائج غير محسومه ولكن
البعض قد يعتبر بعد كل ما تقدم انه نتائج
ربما تكون محسومه فعلا مع كل هذه الامور
التي يقوم اردوغان الان بمحاوله تجعلها
تصب في صالح ان كان على المستويات
الداخليه او الاقليميه
نعم مساء الخير للجميع اولا بدي اهنيكم
على التقرير المفصل للفعلا يحمل اخر
التطورات يعني اخر
الحاله السياسيه الانتخابيه التي نناقشها
في الداخل التركي في هذه
الساعات شكرا
الانتخابات ستكون مختلفه عن الانتخابات
التي جرت في السابق تحديدا بالنسبه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه 2014 و 2018 رئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان كما تتذكر انت ايضا وقتها فاز
بفارق كبير على منافسين سواء كان في عام
على مرشح اليسار لحزب الشعب الهمم
الجمهوري الان همم هذه همم المعركه يعني
حسب استطلاعات الراي الكثير من استطاعات
الراي قبل شهرين تحديدا
تقعد تجادلك ابره تميل بشكل واضح سواء كان
في الانتخابات البرلمانيه او في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الى صالح قوى
المعارضه الان في العشرين الاخرين بدانا
نرى التحول في استطلاعات الراي صعود جديد
لحزب للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان النقطه
المهمه انا وانت نناقشها مطولا ربما في
المرحله المقبله هي هل سيكون سيناريو طبعا
هذا من عنده هل سيكون هناك فوز مثلا
للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وصولي مره اخرى
الى الرئاسه
وتعثر حزب ايه حزب العداله والتنميه في ان
يصل ويحصل على الاغلبيه البرلمانيه هذه
مشكله الان حسب الكثير من استطلاعات الراي
ان يفوز اردوغان وان لا يصل معه حزمه الى
قياده البرلمان في الاغلبيه او في
الاكثريه الان في نقطه ايضا مهمه
مطروح من الان
ليش فوز اردوغان وخساره الحزب ليش موضوع
لانه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان بالمقارنه مع
ارقام قبل شهرين الان عاده واسترد حوالي
ست او سبع نقاط على الاقل حسب شركات
الاستطلاع في شارع الاخرين بسبب اكثر من
موقف اشرتم انتم الى الكثير منها قبل قليل
في التقرير وفي المعلومات
باسباب داخليه ولاسباب خارجيه ايضا هذه
التحول في التعامل مع اكثر من ملف اكثر من
مساله بالنسبه للحزب حتى الان في توحد
يصفوف المعارضه الطويله السداسيه الان
عندها هذا الصقر حتى اللحظه ليه تسجل هذا
الاختراق تحت السد البرنامج هل ينجح
الرئيس اردوغان في همم يعني سحب حزمه معه
ايضا لان قبل في نقطه اخيره باختصار ايضا
تحدث عنها اضيفها الى السيناريوهات
باختصار جدا انه مساله همم الانتخابات
المبكره نعم مطروحه لكن في سيناريو جديد
ايضا نناقشه الان هي
ايمن سيكون شكل هذه الانتخابات
البرلمان اذا قال انه لن يدعم القرار
الانتخابات حزب العداله والتنميه وحليفه
حزب الحركه القوميه اليمني لا يستطيع ان
يعني يصدر قرار من هذا النوع في البرلمان
لانه يحتاج الى 366 صوت لا يملك هذه
النسبه اذا السيناريو الان الجديد وهو
باختصار انه هل الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
سيذهب اتجاه فسخ البرلمان او حل البرلمان
ليعلن انتخابات مبكره وعندها نذهب وراء
السيناري من هذا النوع تمام الان المعارضه
التركيه في الاخبار العاجله على الشاشه
تقول لا ندعم اجراء انتخابات رئاسيه مبكره
همم على القانون الانتخابي الحالي ولا
يمكن ولا يمكن ان ندعم تنظيم انتخابات
رئاسيه مبكره ولكن وفقا لقانون 2000 2018
ماذا يعني ذلك
يعني انه المعارضه تريد ان تشترط على
الحزب الحاكم اذا كان في رغبه في الذهاب
وراء انتخابات مبكرا ينبغي ان تتم عمليه
الانتخابات بالتعامل مع قانون الانتخابات
القديم السابق لماذا لانه تريد ان تحسن من
كم موضوعها الانتخابي ال ال على مستوى
الخارطه السياسيه
يعني اذا اصابته هذا المقصود بس انا كنت
عم بسال
الوقت
بس يعني نحن قلنا انه حدود اكبر عدد من
المواقف لانه استطلاعات الراي صارت عم
بتجيب له نتائج افضل بس ايضا عندما يصدر
القضاء حكما بحبس منافس اساسي
وقيادي تركي همم يعني جديد في المشهد همم
هو اكرم امام اوغلو وعندما يحرم حزب اساسي
ايضا همم له 56 من المقاعد البرلمانيه من
التمويل الانتخابي وربما يحل ربما يحذر
وربما بعد اعضاء فقط وليس كله يعني نكون
امام حمل يمكن وصفها بحمله يعني همم قمعه
المعارضه لوقفها عن اي تقدمات انتخابيه
مقبله بحكم السلطه التي يملكها
الى حزب الشعوب الديمقراطيه الذي عنده هذا
الصوت في المناطق جنوب شرق تركيا صوت
الكرديه همم عنده مش لانه هو ليس جزء من
المعارضه السداسيه التي تشكلت همم قبل
اشهر وهذه المعارضه ايضا لا تريد ان تنسق
معه وتريد ان تبقي خارج اي قرار تحالف
لماذا لانه كما تعرف انت ايضا في عنده
اكثر من التهاب اليه سبب علاقته مع
موضوع ملف حزب ال همم العمال الان في في
نقطه مهمه انا باختصار اظن انه حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي هذا الحزب الان سيكون له هذا
التاثير وهذا الثقل ايضا كبيده القبان في
حسن
الانتخابي عنده حوالي تسعه بالمئه من
الاصوات وقادر على التاثير اذا ما قرر
الذهاب كبلوك قوه ثقل موحده يعني مستوى
الحزب لدعم مرشح او المعارضه في
الانتخابات البرلمانيه عنده حدوث كبيره ان
يلعب هذا الدوري هل المعارضه الكلاسيكيه
الان الطاوله السداسي ستعطيها هذه الفرصه
علينا ان نتميز انا وان بعض الوقت نعرف
كيف ستكون العلاقه بين هذه المعارضه وبين
حزب الشعوب بس لانه انتهى وقتنا احنا تريت
شكرا ههه دكتور سمير صلحه الاستاذ في
العلاقات الدوليه شكرا جزيلا على هذه
المعلومات والشروحات تحياتي اليك
في العربيات 360 ايضا بعد الفاصل الامير
هاري يروي كيف تعرض للضرب على يد شقيقه
الاكبر واستطلاع راي يؤكد ان البريطانيين
غير متعاطفين معه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
داخل مجلس النواب الامريكي في سعيه للوصول
الى منصب رئيس المجلس وفي اليوم الثالث
للتصويت وبعد سبع جولات لم يتمكن مكارت
بعد من توحيد حزبه الفائز بالاغلبيه في
المجلس حيث تنفس ضده الجمهوريه المتشدد
بايرن دونالدز والذي يرى ان مقار في صاحب
مواقف ضعيفه هذه صور مباشره بالمناسبه
نراها الاستمرار عمليات التصويت وجلسات
مجلس النواب الامريكي في الجوله الثامنه
التي يذهب اليها النواب الامريكيون الان
من التصويت وتظهر المؤشرات انه سيخسرها
ايضا
من داخل مبنى الكونجرس الامريكيه حيث
جلسات التصويت على انتخاب رئيس المجلس
النواب مراسله العربيه ناديه البلبيسي
اهلا بك معنا ناديه اخر المعلومات حول
الجوله الثامنه واسباب الفشل المتكرر
الثامنه ايضا لسبب بسيط وهو عنا المرشح
اليميني المتشدد الذي هو يعني بحداته غير
مهم من هي شخصيته لكن من يدعمهم العشرين
ما يسمون الان بالمتمردين وهم ما يسمى
بكله الحريه لفريده كوكيز اختاروه حتى
يجعلوه عقب امامه وصول كيف المقافي الى
مجلس النواب وبالتالي ونحن الان نشاهد
التصويت معا ااه لا يعني بشكل عام نستطيع
ان ننتظر الى نتائج حتى يصل الى 200 واحد
او الى اخره لانه بايرن دونالدز حتى الان
حصل على اكثر من سبعه طالما هناك خمس
اصوات معارضه لكن هذا يعني بانه لن يصل
الى الرقم السحري المطلوب وهو 218
بانه لا يستطيع حتى تاجيل التصويت على
اللجنه بالامس استطاعه نوعا ما يعني ان
يؤجله حتى منتصف اليوم لكن اليوم بالتحديد
قد يذهبون الى جلسه
وهذا سيكون كارثي بالنسبه لمكاسي لانه كما
تعرف هناك تمركز في المعسكرين معسكر يميني
متطرف يختطف هذه الاجنده للجمهوريين
ممثلين ب 20 نائب يريدون فرد اجننتتهم على
كيف المقصي ومقاصي حتى لو استطاع 200 سم
الذي لديه ان يقدم تنازلات لهم هذا يعني
بنو سيكون رئيس ضعيف جدا وسيكون لديهم قوه
ونفوذ في اللجان وهي النقطه المهمه
بالنسبه للجمهوريين والديمقراطيين معه همم
هل همم خيار مرشح بانه اذا همم يعني وصلوا
الى طريق مسدود تماما ان يفاوض
الديمقراطيين على قبول همم يعني شخص يمكن
ان يؤثر قرارهم في هذا في هذا انتخابات او
لا
احد الخيارات النظريه لا اتوقع ان تحدث
يعني الانقسام الحاصل في الولايات المتحده
منذ تولي الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
الحكم سواء كان في الكونغرس او حتى في
مراكز القياده الاخرى في الولايات المتحده
هو واضح واصبح ربما عميقا
فصعب ان نعود لايام حتى الرئيس بوش عندما
كانت هناك محاولات من الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين العمل معا اعتقد انه مجرديه
تسريبات ليس اكثر ربما لتخويف الجناح
المتشدد بانهم يستطيعون ان يذهبوا الى
الديمقراطيين لكن بالنهايه يعني بغض النظر
حتى لو كانت الديمقراطيين سعداء بهذه
النتيجه وفي كل مره على فكره همم ثمان
جولات حتى الان كل مره حكيم جيفرز وهو
ممثل الديمقراطين وسيكون رئيس الاقليه في
مجلس النواب يذكر اسمه يحصل على نفس الرقم
212 يتم التصفيق له بشكل حاد ويظهر وحده
الديمقراطيين على عكس السور بهذا التمزق
والتجذب التجاذب في داخل الحزب الجمهوري
وبالتالي اين نذهب من الان لا احد يعرف هل
هي جولات مستمره حتى على فكره لو تم طرح
اسماء اخرى غير طبعا همم كيف المقال في
همم قد النظر من هي هذه الاسماء هذا
الجناح
ستيفن همم
لا يفرق معهم الاسم هم يريدون تنفيذ
الجلده وبالتالي 20 نائب يميني متشدد يؤمن
بالنظريات المؤامره موالله للرئيس ترامب
حتى هم لم يسمعوا له عندما طلب منهم
التصويت لكلمه مستعدين ان يجرؤ الحزب الى
الى الحديد اذا اردت او الى الوحل حتى
يثبت هذه الاجنده ويبدو حتى الان بانهم
غير مستعدين عن التنازل على التنازل طاهر
مسلسل طويل امريكي طويل هذه المراه شكرا
جزيلا لك من داخل مبنى الكونجرس الامريكي
مراسله العربيه ناديه بالبسي شكرا جزيلا
على الاقل من صوفي على الهواء ههه
[موسيقى]
مجددا تعود دراما العائله المالكه
البريطانيه وبسبب الامير هاري نجل الملك
تشارلز الثالث الذي وسعت الهوى بينه وبين
العائله المالكه نتيجه خلافات بدات منذ
زواجه بالممثله الامريكيه مجان ماركت اصدر
الامير هاري سيرته الذاتيه تحت عنوان سبار
والترجمه ربما احتياطي مع الترجمه
حيث يصف هاري نفسه بانه تمت معاملته كقطعه
غيار احتياطيه للتوريث في العائله الماليه
اذا ما اصاب شقيقه الامير وليام مكروه
ذلك بالطبعه قبل ان ينجب وليام ابنائه او
اذا اصاب اي مكروه شقيقه ويليام بالاحرف
ابرز ما كشفه هاري في كتابه هي مواجهه في
منزله في لندن مع اخيه وليام الذي ضربه
عام 2019 بعد ان تطور نقاش حاد الى اشتباك
جسدي ذهب
معه حول ازمته مع الصحافه ولكن يقول هاري
ان شقيقه كان فاقدا لاعصابه قبل ان يدخل
منزله اشتكى وليام من ميغان ماركل فقال له
هاري انه يردد الروايات الصحفيه
ويتوقع من اخيه ان يقف الى جانبه لكنه لم
يكن عقلانيا فندفع الشقيقان للصراخ على
بعضهما البعض قال هاري لاخيه انه يتصرف من
موقف قوه لانه الثاني في ترتيب العرش
انذاك وقال ان ويليام لم يفهم ابدا معنى
ان يكون مجرد قطعه غيار احتياطيه بحسب
هاري قال له ويليام ان ميجان ماركل صعبه
ووقح ومزيفه ليحتدم الحديث بينهما ثم خرج
الامير هاري من الغرفه وذهب الى المطبخ
وقال لوليام انه خائف منه لحق به وليام ثم
امسك بياخه قميصاري ومزق القلاده التي
تلتف حول عنق عنقه ثم طرحه ارضا يقول هاري
انه سقط بقوه على وعاء على الارض وتعرض
ظهره لاصابه قويه استلقى على الارض للحظات
ثم نهض وطالب شقيقه بالخروج من منزله
وليم لم يخرج طلبه ان يرد عليه الضربه
بالضربه كما كان يتشاجران في طفولتهما لكن
هذه رفض ليغادر وليام بعد ان اعتذر وطالب
هاري بعدم اخبار مجان ماركل بمحدث يقول
هاري انه لم يخبر زوجته بمحدث الا بعد ان
لاحظت وجود خدوش وكدمات على ظهره فاخبرها
بهجوم شقيقه عليه لم تتفاجئ ميغان ماركل
ولم تغضب ايضا يقول هاري انها كانت حزينه
للغايه بسبب ما حدث
[موسيقى]
بعد ذلك ينتقل هاري للحديث عن والده الملك
تشارلز الثالث وكيف تمت معاملته في صغره
كشخص احتياطي يروي قصه سمعها ان والده قال
لوالدته الاميره ديانا يوم ولادته رائع
لقد منحتني وريثا ثم قطعه غيار
ثم يروي هاري لقاء جمعه مع والده وشقيقه
بعد جنازه جده الامير يقول ان والده وقف
بين بنيه المتحاربين وينظر الى الوجهين
الغاضبين ليقول ارجوكم يا اولاد لا تجعلوا
سنوات الاخيره بائسه
[موسيقى]
رغم هذه القصص المؤثره للامير هاري الا
انه لا يبدو انها تلقى الكثير من الاصداء
التي توقعها هاري بل تلقى الاصداء ربما
التي توقعها القصر حتى الان التزم قصر
كتاب هاري الجديد حتى ان الخبراء المهتمين
بالشؤون الملكيه يرون ان القصر يتعمد
الصمت تقول كنزي سكوفيلد الخبيره في
الشؤون الملكيه ان العائله مرت بما هو
اسوا من هذه الاسماء هذه الحقيقه وتعتقد
انه مجرد وقت قبل ان ينسى الناس هذه القصه
الجديده اما اذا رد القصر فمعنى ذلك ان
دراما هاري وماجين ستستمر اما الكاتب
كريستوفر اندرسون الذي كتب مؤخرا كتابا عن
الملك تشارلز الثالث فنقل عن مصادر قولها
ان طلبا اعتذارا من القصر الا انه لن يحصل
على ما يريد اما بعيدا عن الخبراء فللناس
ايضا موقف مشابه حيث كشفت استطلاعات الراي
الاخيره ان الامير هاري فشل في اقناع
البريطانيين بهذه المذكرات ليجد استطلاع
اجرته يوغاف ان واحدا 81 بالمئه من
المريطانيين لم يهتموا بقصه حياه هاري
اضافه الى انها كشفت انخفاضا كبيرا في
شعبيته
اصبرها يعني
لديك هاري وميكان الذين يكسبان عشرات
الملايين من الجنيهات لنشر غسيلهم القذر
في الاماكن العامه اعتقد انه امر صادم بغض
النظر عما يحدث بين افراد الاسره الملكيه
لكن هل تريد حقا نشرهاالى
العالمات الاخوه لكنني لا اعتقد انها بهذا
السوق
لكن في نفس الوقت اذا حدث شيء ما عند اذن
يجب ان يعرف الناس
لديها مشاكل انا متاكد من انه يعاني من
مشاكل اكبر بسبب ما ولد فيه لكن لا تفعل
ذلك بهذه الطريقه يمكن القيام بحلها داخل
العائله لكنه اراد ان يعرف العالم كله
بغسيله القذر
معنى من لندن الان صحفيه جوستين ايليا
اهلا بك معنا جوسلين مره جديده على شاشه
العربيه يعني ماذا تقول لك كل هذه
المعلومات اولا بخصوص طبيعه العلاقه بين
الشقيقين ولماذا يصر هاري في هذا العمر
المبكر همم ينشر كل هذه التفاصيل
الوضع الان الى مساله تجاريه بحث لم تعد
مساله مشاكل عائليه او مشكله ما بين
الامير هاري وطريقه المعامله القصر
والاشخاص او الاعضاء البارزين في العائله
الملكه له هو لزوجته همم كل ما يحصل الان
ليس سوى قضيه ترويجيه همم عاده تحصل قبل
طرح اي كتاب في في الاسواق وهذا ما يحصل
لقد ااه قام باجراء المقابلتين الاولى في
الولايات المتحده وقام باجراء المقابلتين
في نفس اليوم لقناه امريكيه واحده وهي
السي بي اس للقناه الثالثه في بريطانيا
وتعمد ذلك لان لديه مسؤوليه همم تجاه دار
النشر
لتحقيق مبيعات همم
عظيمه جدا وهذا ما هو متوقع ولو ان الشعب
البريطاني وحتى الامريكيين لم ااه لم يعد
مهتمين همم مثل ذي قبل بقضيه الامير هاري
وزوجته
او لعادات ربما فيما يتعلق بالعائله همم
الملكيه بانه تكون بحب يكون محافظين
بالقصاص المتعلقه فيهم للحفاظ على الرمزيه
ربما او في اسباب اخرى ربما تغير العصر لا
نعم طاهر يعتمد هذا الامر على لانه ليس
جميع الموجودين في بريطانيا او المقيمين
في بريطانيا او البريطانيين ليسوا جميعا
من المؤيدين للعائله الملكه او الملكيين
وهناك من هم من المحافظين ولكن تعب الجميع
من هذه المساله ومن هذه القضيه ومن هذه
المهاترات العائليه ونحن نتكلم عن عائله
بعظمه واهميه العائله الملكيه في بريطانيا
فهناك من تعب من الموضوع وهناك من يعني
همم لم يعد لديه الرغبه بسماع القيل
والقال في الموضوع وهذا هو الامر فاعتقد
بانها مبيعات الكتاب ستكون كبيره جدا
من المتوقع يعني همم من غير اي مناسبه ان
يكون الكتاب رقم واحد من همم من حيث
المبيعات في بريطانيا لانه هناك يعني نوع
من الحشريه لدى الجميع لمعرفه ماذا
لان لديه مسؤوليه كما قلت في في مستهل
الحديث امام دار النشر بتقديم معلومات
انه هذا الشيء تجاري الا يتحمل القصر
مسؤوليه في طريقه التعاطي معه ومع زوجته
في اصول الامور الى ما وصلت اليه
هلا همم
لقد تركيز خاصه من قبل على قضيه العنصريه
وهذه اساء كبيره جدا للعائله الملكيه ولكن
نحن لا نستطيع ان ننسى بانها تاتي من
الولايات المتحده وهذه البلاد معروفه
بقضايا عنصريه كبيره جدا اكثر من التي اا
نسمعها في بريطانيا وعن القشر الملكيه لا
احد يمكن همم بان همم يثبت بان ما تقوله
همم كان قد حصل او لا هذا يعني حصلت
الكثير الكثير من الاشياء حصلت داخل القصر
وداخل جدران القصر فهي يعني من مصلحتها
بان تقول همم هذه الاقاويل ولكن كما ذكرت
في مستهل همم الموضوع بان يعني لم يعد
هناك نوع من يعني الناس عن همم تبين اهم
يعني اهميه او ان عم بتميل الامير هاري
همم لان ما يقوم به هو زعزعه
صوره العائله الملكه وخاصه لاخيه اكثر من
صوره والده الملك تشارلز الثالث
على العرش بعد والده همم هذا قد يؤثر
كثيرا عليها همم اعتقد انه انت كمان مش من
المحلزين كثيره لهاري وماجن
بصراحه
ابدا لان انا لان انا يعني اعتقد بان
الفرابط العائلي مهم جدا جدا ولا يجوز بان
يقوم بمقامه بهزازه صوره عائله ونشر غسيل
العائله على الملائكه ولدي بعد التحفظات
بالنسبه لمجال ماكر اكيد انها ليست حافظات
شخصيه ولكن منذ البدايه منذ ان تزوجت
الامير هاري وهي تعرف من هو امير وهي
تزوجت همم ابن عائله عاديه وتزوجت شخص
يعني تابع لمؤسسه وهذا ما لا يريده فهو
يلتقي ما يريده وما لا يريدك
اسبابه همم من ايام ولدته والتعامل معها
وظروف وفاتها وصولا الى التعامل مع زوجته
ومعه تحديدا على كل شكرا يقدر النقاش
مفتوحه شكرا جزيلا لك الكاتبه صحفيه من
لندن تحياتي اليك
في العربيه 360 ايضا موجه الطقس دافئ في
اوروبا تحرم السياح من موسم التزلج
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
حول العالم اجمع به عرض بوتين وقف النار
او الهدنه على الاقل في السادس من يناير
في اوكرانيا اختارت مجله كونديناست تربلر
بريطانيا المتخصصه في مجال السفر والسياحه
مدينه العلا شمال غرب السعوديه ضمن عجائب
الدنيا السبع لعام 20/03
اصبحت شهره عالميه نظرا لما تختزله من
تاريخ وارث واثار لم يكشف النقاب عن
معظمها حتى اليوم وتضم العلا معالم
تاريخيه انسانيه يظهر من بينها موقع الحجر
الذي بنته ابداعات الحضاره النبطيه وسجل
الموقع بوصفه اول موقع تراث عالمي ضمن
لائحه منظمه اليونسكو في السعوديه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله
[موسيقى]
صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 هي من شنغهاي
الصينيه صوره تذكرنا بمشاهدناها عام 2019
مع تفشي جائه كورونا والضغط على
المستشفيات حيث تعود هذه المشاهد من جديد
ويتكدس المرضى المصابون بكرونا الى جواري
بعضهم البعض مع الخوف من انهيار النظام
الصحي كما حدث من قبل
تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 لنائب رئيس
مجلس الامن القومي الروسيهدف حيث قال ان
ارساله القطر روسيه مزوده بصواريخ فرط
صوتيه هديه روسيا لحلف شمال الاطلسي في
العام الجديد وقال مدريديف ان روسيا
ستتحدث مع النيتو بلغه القوه اذا كان
الحلف لا يفهم سوى تلك اللغه مضيفا ان
روسيا ستسعى للانتقام مقابل كل مواطن يقتل
منها
والى فيديو اليوم في العربيه 360 وهو من
البوسنه وتحديدا من الجبال الواقعه جنوب
سراييفو حيث شهدت هذه الجبال خاليه من
الثلوج
والمتزلجين بسبب موجه طقس دافئ تسببت في
اضرار ان الموسم السياحي خصوصا وان هذا
الوقت كان يعد من اكثر الاسابيع ازدحاما
في الموسم
شكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام على متابعه
العربيه
360 طبعا نحن نذكر بان مجلس النواب
الامريكي فشل حتى الان في انتخابات رئيسا
له مطار في فشلت في الجوله الثامنه ايضا
والامور تتجه الان الى جوله التاسعه مع
ثلاث جولات في كل يوم مع تعهد
النواب
النائب الجمهوري جيتس الذي قال انه لو
استمر الامر لشهور لم يتردد في منع
انتخابات مكارتي ومكارتي يتهممه المتشددون
في الحزب الجمهوري بانه معتدل ولم يكن همم
لم يتخذ مواقف سليمه اذا همم قضيه ترامب
مثلا اخبار الساعه مستمره وهي الان بعده
صهيب شراير ويتابع هذا الموضوع بدون
جاكسون صحيح اننا على مجلس النواب
الامريكي فشل الاخر همم كما تفضلتهم عشرون
نائبا جمهوريه يرفضون لمكرتي يعتقدون انه
جمهوري ولكن بعيون ديموقراطيه يعتبرون انه
معتدل اكثر من اللازم نص جمهوري يعني نعم
اتفضل